[Music]
hi everybody i'm dave stassen alongside
jeff worthing and welcome to the annual
east west bowl as we get ready to watch
some of the best college players in the
nation showcase their skills in a
classic showdown between east and west
and there really are some characters on
this year's squads aren't there jeff
that's right dave it does seem like the
most flamboyant personalities came to
the forefront and they are here let's
meet the players from the east
demarcus williams university of georgia
t.j jackson wayne state university
tavares king merrimack college
todd royal smoochie wallace
university miami the squarius green
junior university of notre dame ibrahimo
zeus
university of tennessee at chattanooga
jack marius tax theratrix michigan state
university the isaiah t billings club
coast carolina university the jasper
probing crux iii
south carolina state university
leo's maxwell jillian's
east carolina university
javaris jamar jamaris and lamar
university of middle tennessee devoine
shower handle university of southern
mississippi jingle mccringleberry penn
state university
la carpetron duke marriott
florida atlantic university
the dinklage morgue
university of south florida
x miss jackson flax and waxing
california university of pennsylvania
we're going to be looking for big plays
all game long from tyrol smoochie
wallace and let's not forget the tight
ends ibrahim moyesus and hingle
mckringleberry they've both had amazing
seasons that's right jeff now let's meet
the players from the west
[Music]
jefferson
texas a m the cluster how dunkin chug
university of wisconsin
swerverton l gooding's flat
saskatchewan university cuatro cuatro
san jose state university
osmatazz buckshank
stanford university
these are 12 washing beard
jones college
shakira kwan t.g.i.f carter
university of northern arizona x wayne
at aliciousness missouri western state
university sequester grundlepleth md
adam state
scores philosoraptor malloys south
dakota state university tj aj rj
backslashes fourth the fifth
i'll be in college
[Music]
san diego state university donkey teeth
boise state university tork
lewis
nevada state
penitentiary the player formerly known
as mouse cop university of missouri
colombia
dan smith
byu
[Music]
hello thanks for calling mario's pizza
this is carlos speaking hello
we would like a large pie with a
pepperoni pineapple and cheesy crust
large pepperoni with pineapple and
cheesy crust
we
would also like a large pie with bacon
pineapple
and cheesy breath large bacon pineapple
with cheesy crust okay is that gonna
complete your order sir you know what
let me gauge the room uh guys are we
gonna want another pizza let me just
who's hungry show her hands let me see
them
one two three keep them up four five six
ah having a party
yup pretty big one two come on guys keep
them up hugo summer hands food you know
what let's play it safe let's get
another pie
pineapple all right um
oh you guys are gonna need cheesy crust
on the third good question i'll gauge
the room hey guys do we want cheesy
crust on the third okay yeesh that is a
resounding yes for cheesy crust on the
third
claire says you read her mind claire huh
i like that name it's a good one oh also
uh my boy andy over here is saying you
have something called chicken poppers is
she cute uh who's that and what now
claire oh
her body's like a four anyway we would
also
how do you mean
let's just say she's kind of a big girl
that's all good
that's all superficial man i like claire
for what's inside don't even know claire
yo but for real though i feel like i do
know claire man
put me on the phone with her
uh
you don't need to speak to claire no i
do
you know what
i gotta level with you man
i
sir
i'm sorry i i i didn't mean to
get in between you guys no
it's quite all right
twas a while ago before she blinked up
my current girlfriends live
body
tan face
tan
but anyway claire yeah
i hit that sexually
and uh as did my boy hugo hell even
bubba got some of that
so just wanted you to know used goods to
use goods so you wouldn't care if i
asked her out
well
let me do it for you hey claire this guy
from the pizza place wants to date you
too poor all right i'll let him down
wait wait wait wait no
tell her
no i'm not a rich man
but i'm a good man
tell her claire i believe in destiny
and i believe that we've always known
that our soul mate was out there the
moment that we
had that unspoken connection about the
cheesy crust
i realized that you were always the one
because
and i know this sounds corny
but that moment
was just like
simple
[Music]
wow
you really do care about claire
i do
oh my god claire just got shot what no
oh it just came through the window it
was a bullet in the neck oh claire's
down she's dead she's dead i'm calling
the cops she's dead
chinese it is
[Applause]
dude i am sorry we're late and it
happens man she talked about how we're
supposed to be in the car at 6 45 i'm
like all right uh-oh
tell me my dumb ass ain't sitting in the
car waiting until 7 15. um okay when i
track my wife down 20 minutes later
she's stepping up the damn shower
talking about can i help you see that's
crazy right there craig i looked this
woman in the eye i said
[ __ ] you told me 6 45. huh you said
that yeah i said
[ __ ] then i laid it out but you said
[ __ ] though
you said [ __ ]
yeah you gotta see the fireplace
downstairs in the living room
okay
don't play games man just tell me what
you're doing exactly it's like say what
you mean mean what you say is that so
hard it's like last week man we going
out to dinner right i'm like where do
you want to go she's like you decide
uh-oh i'm like all right outback
steakhouse she's like nah mm-hmm i'm
like straight-up chili's she's like
no no daryl i named seven more wrestlers
no craig no finally said taylor's the
place i know she wants to go out in the
first place right right she look at me
she said if that's where you want to go
no she did it right that's where i want
to go daryl i looked my woman in the eye
socket i told her straight out i just
said it man i said it i said i said i
said
i said babe hey guys hey girl how you
doing man you having a good time are you
seeing the bedroom
washing machine look at this machine is
huge you get a whole bunch of clothes
and not watching this scene it's like
hey baby i'm gonna take her back up to
the kitchen and show her the dishwasher
hey daryl yeah baby i want a kitchen
island just like the one upstairs yeah
you're gonna get it too
i love you
i love you
i said [ __ ]
if you wanted to go to taylor's just
tell a brother you want to go with
taylor
you said that oh hell yeah man i laid it
out right i said i said i said
i said
[ __ ] i'm the man of the house you said
[ __ ] though
you called your wife a [ __ ]
oh yeah
huh daryl where are those guys
i don't girl let me show you this
so she's like why don't you win a movie
we both like no she didn't after i spent
25 minutes in the goddamn blockbuster
craig i looked this woman in her optic
stems and i says i said
i says
you said that ain't nothing but a thing
but you said [ __ ] though
yep
hey honey uh craig just give me the
neighborhood tour
so then she's like i didn't know we'd be
doing so much walking no uh i'm like i
didn't tell you to wear those shoes she
said don't raise your voice at me what
dare
roll
i look this woman
dead in the windows of her soul
i said
[Music]
i said
i said be
[Music]
all right y'all gather round gather
round welcome gentlemen what a beautiful
and blessed day for an auction
all right y'all get on up there
put that whip down and see what happens
though straight up i don't care what
plantation i end up on i'm straight
staging a revolt in this [ __ ]
hills yeah we have lot a
lot b and lot c uh three dollars on la
day four dollar five five dollars going
once twice three times sold lotte goes
to the man in the black
i mean good yeah
i'm glad i didn't get sold because i
don't want to be owned by another human
being whoever buys me they better kill
me the first day i'm gonna go buck wild
on the whole operation
next one get up on up there now
oh it's okay
six dollars on lotte
seven dollars eight
nine nine dollar going once twice three
times soul
okay well you have to buy that dude it's
a no-brainer i mean that guy's huge
massive individuals that's two of me
anybody would buy him i'd buy that dude
my question is how did they catch him
next
two dollars on lotte two dollars going
once twice three times soul see now that
surprises me that is interesting to say
the least well it just seems like at a
certain point it's like do they even
know what they're looking at it's like
the whole criteria seems just a little
inconsistent i mean at some point i want
to be on live yeah
can a brother get on lotte
next
oh here we go here we go good pleasure
give him hell all right okay eight
dollars on la day going once twice three
times whole how does that no not true
that's gobbledygook okay that can't be
true because what can you do look at him
what could he pick a cotton plant is
like this tall yes i'm saying no offense
brother i'm just saying i'll sense taken
what
it's not am i wrong is he's not shorty
shorts but you are actually short in
real life in the world
enough
i will not have my reputation tainted
selling superficial bigoted slaves
superficial did that really just come
out of your mouth that's it
this auction's over
auctions
no is it ain't over it's not over what
i'm strong y'all i'm very sure i can
sleep in a bucket i'm fast i got stamina
no i don't look at me no magic my worst
quality is that i'm a perfectionist have
i mentioned this docile
i am agreeable to a fault you should
have seen the dude who asked me to get
on the boat when we came over here not a
violent bomb
no big deal never seen a boat in my life
all right listen up y'all
i'm your substitute teacher mr garvey
i taught school for 20 years in the
inner city
so don't even think about messing with
me
y'all feel me
mm-hmm okay let's take a roll here
jay kwellen
where's jay quillinette
no jay quellon here
yeah
uh do you mean jacqueline
okay
so that's how it's gonna be
y'all to play okay then
i've got my eye on you jquery
but latke
where is balaka at
no block out here today
yes sir
my name is blake
are you out of your goddamn mind
blake
what
do you want to go to warble lucky no
cause we could go to war no i'm for real
i'm for real
so you better check yourself
d nice
is there a d nice
if one of y'all
says some silly ass name
this whole class is gonna feel my wrath
now d nice
do you mean denise son of a [ __ ]
you say your name right right now denise
say it right denise correctly denise
right denise right
d nice that's better thank you
now a-a-ron
where are you
where is a-a-ron right now
no a-a-ron huh
well you better be sick
dead or mute a-a-ron here
oh man
why didn't you ask me the first time i
said it huh huh i'm just you know i'm
just asking you know i said it like four
times so why didn't you say it the first
time i said a-a-ron
because it's pronounced aaron
you done messed up hey ron now take your
ass on down to osak hennessy's office
right now and tell him exactly what you
did
who oh shag hennessy
principal o'shaughnessy get out of my
goddamn classroom before i break my foot
off in your ass insubordinate
and churlish
timothy
present
thank you
[Music]